[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue aujourd'hui paris
saclay tv vous emmène dans le nouveau
temple de l'impression industrielle 3d
en france nous sommes à l'additif
factory aube nouvelle plateforme de
digiteo saclay au cea l'innovation il en
sera aussi question avec la seconde
édition de thé this day a system x
l'occasion pour 10 doctorants de
présenter leurs travaux
mais attention en trois minutes
seulement et devant un large public
ils étaient étudiants ils sont devenus
entrepreneurs découvrez giraud lift et
énergie skweres ces deux start-up de
paris saclay ont réussi à décrocher leur
ticket pour las vegas et le c es le
consumer electronics show c'était dans
janvier dernier et c'est bien simple
c'est le plus grand rendez vous mondial
de l'innovation technologique en
électronique
de quoi faire rêver les participants du
hackaton next generation organisé par
proto 204 est porté par le pea paris
saclay
c'est le nouveau temple de l'impression
industrielle 3d en france l'additif
factory homme a pris ses quartiers ici
sur le site du cea de paris saclay cette
nouvelle plateforme veut regrouper les
acteurs de la recherche
les fournisseurs de technologies et les
entreprises
rencontre avec philippe mathot directeur
du liszt institut de ceatec
[Musique]
bienvenue ici sur cette plateforme a dit
yves factory iob à digiteo saclay la
plateforme additifs actuelle c'est une
plateforme ouverte qui va mutualiser les
moyens de la recherche ici sur le
plateau de saclay et les moyens de
l'industrie pour progresser ensemble sur
les nouvelles technologies en matière de
fabrication dit yves en matière de
matériaux en matière d'algorithmes en
matière de simulation et de réalisation
ce sont les grands domaines qui vont
tous nous concerner recherche et
industrie pour avancer ensemble ici en
région ile-de-france sur la fabrication
additive nous sommes ici à digiteo sakli
étaient au sec les vous êtes sur un site
du cea mais un site qui est ouvert vous
vous trouvez toutes les équipes du ces
en matière de contrôle non destructif le
contrôle c'était absolument important
dans la fabrication dit c'est vraiment
ce qui va permet de certifier des pièces
il ya un grand enjeu autour du contrôle
du soutif de la fabrication et yves
deuxième enjeu la simulation vous
pouvoir simuler finalement tous ces
nouveaux procédés de fabrication vous
avez aussi enfin et nous sommes heureux
de les accueillir les équipes du cetim
qui à l'occasion de la plateforme
additifs acteurs iob s'installent ici
sur le plateau de saclay à digiteo
saclay quelques exemples de pièces qui
sont réalisés par la plateforme additifs
actu rugby si vous avez une pièce on
structure la tis 1 c'est vraiment la
structure tout à fait typique tout à
fait caractéristique de la fabrication
d'études
l'additif factory iob va permettre
d'adresser des problématiques de la
fabrication additive métallique en
adressant une métallurgie très
spécifiques
on n'est pas sur la fonderie on n'est
pas sur la forge on est dans un domaine
tout nouveau qui nécessite encore
beaucoup de recherches pour aller plus
vite cet aspect vitesse est important
pour les grands groupes qui ont besoin
de rester toujours en avance dans leur
domaine la diva factory iob a également
accompagné le réseau de sous traitants
des des grands groupes dans leurs choix
techniques dans leur expérimentation
scientifique avant d'avoir à faire des
investissements très lourds
cette plateforme a dit facture yom
n'aurait pas vu le jour sans une
initiative alliance industries du futur
qui va projeter ses ambitions au travers
de la plate forme pour aider notre
industrie à adopter ces nouvelles
technologies
enfin c'est petter n'aurait pas non plus
vu le jour sans le soutien décisif est
très important de la région
ile-de-france dans le cadre de son plan
smart industry qui est mis en avant ces
nouvelles technologies de fabrication et
qui soutient concrètement notre
opération
il avait trois minutes pour convaincre
et pour convaincre un large public dit
dr ont participé au thesis d atys tmx
une deuxième édition organisée en
partenariat avec agent majeur et
l'institut avait des com parmi les
thèmes retenus cette année le véhicule
autonome
la simulation numérique ou encore la
cyber sécurité
on est tous là avec éric perrin
pelletier directeur de l'irt et
systémique
[Musique]
aujourd'hui nous sommes réunis pour
thesis des abscisses tmx c'est la
deuxième édition que l'on organise au
sein de liberté systemx où l'on donne
l'occasion à nos doctorants 30
dr en bas il y en a dix parmi ces 32
présenté en trois minutes
leur thèse devant un public ouvert de
façon à leur permettre de s'exprimer et
de comprendre comme le fait l'université
paris saclay
sur le thème ma thèse en 180 secondes
projeter des années nous faisons cet
exercice en collaboration et en
coopération avec l'it élevé des com qui
possède aussi des doctorants sur des
sujets en proximité puisque ça tourne
principalement autour de la mobilité et
du véhicule autonome donc cette
organisation comprend à la fois une
table ronde qui nous permet de
comprendre quelles sont les
particularités des trains doctorants
dans un institut de recherche par
rapport à un cif ou par rapport à 1
doctorant directement dans une
université et de présenter ces sujets de
thèse est déroulé l'ensemble des
présentations pour chacun des doctorants
on a aussi un jury qui va nommer je
dirais la meilleure présentation ainsi
qu'un prix du jury qui chaque personne
qui a assisté va pouvoir voter pour son
meilleur candidat
le gagnant à l'honneur d'être le gagnant
de cette édition et pourra continuer sa
thèse avec encore plus de confiance et
de respect de ses collègues
donc il s'agit surtout d'un exercice en
propre pour faire connaître expliqué sa
thèse et tout le travail qui a été fait
en préparation par rapport à ça et
surtout le franc intéressant de d'amener
à exprimer techniquement une thèse en
trois minutes et dans l'intéressant un
public large et qui n'a pas forcément le
même niveau technologique et
scientifique du dr
[Musique]
on s'intéresse maintenant au hac at on
expliqué narration organisé porté par le
proto 204 de le paix à paris saclay les
étudiants ont pu présenter leurs
prototypes à des usagers ils ont pu être
coachés par des experts par des mentors
ça a duré 48 heures et au programme de
cette deuxième édition
il y avait donc lhi santé avec un volet
pour les seniors la domotique la
mobilité tout de suite les précisions de
ronan james vous le connaissez c'est le
responsable du proto 204
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est le lancement du hac at
on exploite génération c'est le deuxième
à quatre portes est complètement par le
proto 204 c1 à caton donc 48 heures de
créativité porté par le pays à paris
saclay et le salon out your world qui
rassemble des professionnels des objets
connectés
le music on s'est donné un peu comme
l'année dernière c'était de rassembler
des étudiants logis des usagers en
général de paris saclay pour essayer de
les faire avancer en 48 heures sur une
expérience nous espérons que âgées
comment est ce qu'on peut améliorer
l'expérience et j'ai sur certaines
thématiques à travers un prototype du
ski soit si ce n'est fonctionnel mais en
tout cas qu'on puisse toucher qui
démontre un usage et dans la méthode et
c'est de travailler sur l'ensemble
d'accélération c'est à dire sans
forcément les obliger à faire une
start-up derrière o2 cassin spiritisme
et au delà à la fois sur le modèle
économique sur la communication et
notamment et principalement une
peut-être sa grande usage
parce qu'avec ses participants qu'on a
et qui nous font le plaisir de venir là
pendant 48 heures qu'ils soient
étudiants designers chercheurs mais
coeur industriel
ils ont tous en commun cette compétence
d'ingénierie à ces avancées sur les
technologies donc ça ils ont prescrit
nativement et nous ne parte notre
travail c'est de leur apporter cette
question de l' usage du modèle
économique du design pour faire en sorte
qu'on passe d'un prototype pas une
espèce de prêts produits en tout cas -
vue d'opérer cette magie là dans un
temps assez court un seul à caton il a
trois thématiques
cette année c'est la e-santé il ya un
volet spécifique sur les seniors fort
comment est-ce qu'on aide ces nouvelles
personnes dans l'environnement la
mobilité à paris saclay c'est important
mais aussi autre part comment est-ce
qu'on peut accompagner et puis le smart
building la domotique les bâtiments
intelligents est ce qu'on peut en
inventer une bonne interaction autour de
ces interfaces que sont les bâtiments
après on continue à les soutenir parce
que paraît s'est classée 1re innovation
prix world
donc on va les soutenir notamment en les
mettant dans le bus le fameux proto bus
on a envie de faire de présenter ces
prototypes la auprès des habitants et
des usagers de paris-saclay notamment à
des pollutions ses talents de paris
saclay deviendront peut-être des
entrepreneurs comme ceux qui ont créé et
géré leaf et énergie skweres ces deux
start-up son nez sur votre territoire et
grâce à un concours lancé par la cci
versailles yvelines
elles ont décroché leur ticket pour le
cs le consumer electronics show c'était
à las vegas en janvier dernier
c'est le plus grand rendez vous mondial
de l'innovation technologique en
électronique et pour nos jeunes
entrepreneurs une opportunité incroyable
on les écoute
j'ai pris à l'origine c'était un projet
de recherche d'une thèse de doctorat que
j'ai effectués donc c'est au cours de
cette thèse qu'on a développé le projet
jirau lift différents démonstrateurs
prototypes
c'est pendant cette période qu'a germé
l'idée entrepreneuriale et c'est à la
sortir ça continue bas pourquoi pas la
mener jusqu'à la commercialisation c'est
comme ça que j'ai refusé devant nîmes
start up
las vegas est arrivé un peu rapidement
un peu de manière un peu surprenante
c'est à dire que j'ai juste candidate
est un concours organisé par la cci
versailles yvelines qui permettait aux
deux lauréats d'avoir le voyage et les
billets pour rentrer au salon un du cms
de las vegas et au final je me suis
rangé remporté avec une autre start-up
semaine et énergie square le concours on
a commencé à chercher des partenaires
qu'il y allait et au final
angie avait un stand et nous a proposé
d'exposer notre jolie au final ça s'est
très très bien passé énormément de
visibilité de contact avec des grands
comptes des industriels des
investisseurs sont intéressés ici pour
soi pour l'industrie lisation pour la
commercialisation externe énergie square
c'est l'entreprise que l'on a créé
lorsqu'on était étudiant entrepreneur de
l'université paris-x sacré et donc
c'était avec le pôle entrepreneuriat de
l'université paris saclay et donc c'est
là-bas que le projet est né
la société énergie skweres notre coeur
de métier c'est de développer une
nouvelle technologie de charge pour des
appareils électroniques donc pour des
smartphones des tablettes et donc l'idée
c'est d'avoir des surfaces sur
lesquelles on peut poser tous ces
appareils est chargé tous ces appareils
en même temps et dans le développement
dans notre société on a lancé un premier
produit qui est une surface de recharge
pour smartphones et tablettes
et maintenant on travaille sur des
produits d'intégration qui permettent
d'intégrer nos technologies dont des
tables par exemple pour charger son
ordinateur portable ou directement dans
des appareils électroniques
le cesu est le plus grand salon
d'électronique au monde et nous on
voulait y présenter nos produits puisque
la plupart de nos clients sont là bas
puis on a eu un stand là bas avec
business france dans la délégation
française qui faisait partie de cette
édition du csp retour du sms ont été
très bon pour nous on a rencontré une
soixantaine de clients qui
potentiellement pourrait être intéressée
pour acheter nos produits ou notre
technologie est donc en ce moment on est
en train de relancer toutes ces
personnes ça peut être des fabricants
d'appareils électroniques par exemple
qui ont besoin de notre technologie dans
leurs produits ou des personnes qui ont
tout un tas d'appareils à recharger des
smartphones ou des tablettes par exemple
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve très vite pour un nouveau
numéro de paris saclay tv mais d'ici là
restez informé sur nos réseaux sociaux
sur le site pap.fr et bien sûr sur tv 78
à très bientôt merci
oui
[Musique]
à